cristo
está cerrado tu micro manuel
y listo
hola buenos días una empresa manuel
obregón soy coordinador de
certificaciones aquí en el conelec está
en la secretaría académica del conalep
veo que ya tenemos algunas personas que
están conectadas
cintia desde mexicano y dos con learning
en el 2
yo estoy conectados priscila rodríguez y
hay otras personas más que pero yo no
habría
no está cerrado el manuel estaba abierto
el micro estaba todo bien
así
habían de lo que pasó con si hay un
delay en la reproducción de youtube para
no te preocupes que ya estamos process y
christina quieres quieres
arrancar presentarnos etcétera
así pues gracias por las mismas
y ahora quieres empezar la capacitación
con una introducción y perfecto
permítanme compartir mi pantalla
me refiere a christina que si presentaba
salas compañeras que nos acompañan y
entonces ya puedo arrancar con
no te preocupes buenos días
el día de hoy vamos a tener la sesión
acerca de cómo obtener los
reconocimientos por su esfuerzo mi
nombre es laura camacho esta primera
parte de la capacitación la estará
trabajando en manuel y leonor del equipo
de khan academy para después pasar a
esto de digamos como ponernos al
corriente de lo que he estado haciendo
en el módulo 1 y módulo 2 desde el mes
de agosto sale entonces ahora sí en
manuel todo es tuyo
ok espero que lo que estoy escuchando es
y es en tiempo real así que web
me presentaba hace un momento muchas
gracias por acompañarnos pero ya más
espectadores les agradezco que para que
la grabación también llegue a más
personas aprovechen y le pongan a él el
like me gusta ya lo puse yo y también
nos pongan en sus comentarios y en el
chat que nuestras compañeras van a estar
también atentos a la otra vez
no te preocupes hay un delay siempre en
la reproducción de youtube un micrófono
está cerrado
es creo que más fácil si bajas el
volumen de la de la reproducción de
youtube para que simplemente te
concentres en esta y abras tu micro y en
la reproducción de youtube únicamente
pongas atención si te hacen alguna
pregunta o algo así pero de todas formas
cristina y link están ahí para apoyarnos
con las preguntas que salgan sale aquí
ya nada más sobre tu micro
de manuel
listo porque me transforma se cierra
solo
ya
confirmado verdad estos micrófono
abierto
entonces arrancó ya sin tanta cosa
muchas gracias a todas las personas que
lo están acompañando y muchas gracias
por la invitación que nos acercan
academy para él
la visión acerca de por favor
gracias al segundo síntoma lo esté
entonces voy a voy a empezar con una con
la parte de los antecedentes de khan
academy con aleta muchas gracias a todos
los profesores del problema que nos
están acompañando ya profesores y otros
invitados de otras escuelas también
muchas gracias por acompañarnos
aprovecho para darles mi correo
electrónico y obregón arroba conalep
punto edu.mx cualquier cosa que
requieran por favor
mándenme un correo con todo gusto los
apoyamos estoy obviamente mandando los
unos los saludos y representando la
secretaria académica del conalep a la
doctora marilyn a salazar ya todo el
equipo directivo que tiene nuestro
director el maestro neira entonces
les comento no en la parte de decana
cadivi como conalep oficialmente le
empezamos a trabajar
en el primer encuentro pero antes de
matemáticas docentes de matemáticas del
conalep en en agosto del 2015
dimos una capacitación con los
profesores que ya tenían varios años
trabajando con con khan academy
en el estado de tamaulipas entonces
ellos vinieron le dieron una
capacitación en aquel entonces
khan academy estaba empezando toda su
traducción de contenido al español por
lo cual fue muy interesante
trabajar también cuál es la cuestión de
que los los ejercicios entre cambiaban
de idioma o tienes que empezar a hacer
algunos trucos 2 para poder seguir
avanzando
originalmente utilizamos khan academy
como una herramienta para preparación
para la prueba planeada de nuestros
alumnos y la institución que manejamos
en la secretaría académica es que para
llegar a entregarles algo a los alumnos
siempre capacitamos primero a los
profesores y entonces ellos ya ya los
llevan al alumno
tuvimos esta capacitación muy
interesante y nos enfocamos en cuatro en
cuatro misiones de academy que son las
las primeras cuatro misiones
lejos de ver el temario para no decirles
alguna otra cosa mal
que son matemáticas elementales
aritmética álgebra y fundamentos de
álgebra en esa capacitación
durante 20 horas estuvimos casi las 20
horas trabajando khan academy y también
los probamos nosotros como profesores sí
ya sabíamos todo el contenido cuánto
tiempo nos costaba
hacer los avances no hacer el dominio de
los temas y fue muy interesante yo yo
recuerdo que en aquella ocasión logré
terminar
logré terminar matemáticas elementales
aritmética la dejé como el 40% para el
general como el 15 y fundamentos de
álgebra como el como el 2% no entonces
en el ejercicio curioso porque bueno
como docentes ya conocía a césar esas
partes de matemáticas pero queríamos ver
cómo iba a a
como iba a enfrentarse el alumno a esa
parte entonces después de ese primer
encuentro los docentes de todo el país
fueron a sus planteles
empezaron a trabajar con los alumnos
christina lleva bueno
en aquel entonces el contacto primero
fue con rolando con rolando pasa y en
ellos empezaron a darse cuenta como cómo
iba aumentando la cantidad de docentes y
alumnos que no les usaban en cada
academia a partir de esta capacitación
en lo personal cara camilla lo conocía
un poco antes porque hay un capítulo de
un libro de andrés oppenheimer libro
innovar o morir en el capítulo se llama
salman khan y las escuelas al revés
en ese libro creo que dos años antes
2013 debió haber sido
leí todo este capítulo y en lo personal
empresa cana academia para mi hijo tiene
créditos tenía 37 años entonces empecé a
usarlo en aquel entonces había muy poco
contenido en español entonces yo lo
usaba mucho cornell para explicar los
ejercicios
y en que estaba estaba muy interesante
no recuerdo si usaba los de las misiones
la verdad creo que era algo más con un
general no tenía idea y yo por donde
trabajarlo entonces lo trabajé por donde
pude pero fue muy interesante porque mi
hijo desde aquel entonces özil usando y
y cuando la doctora marianela me comenta
de esta capacitación en khan academy
pues ya lo conoce un poco eso fue una
gran fortuna y por eso fue muy muy fácil
hasta cierto punto incorporarlo
i
creo que tenemos muchos comentarios pero
bueno igual órbitas y los si no me
marcan
después de que empezamos a ver todo este
movimiento en la que contactamos a
rolando por medio de redes sociales
básicamente por medio de linkedin y los
contextos rapidísimo
tuvimos videollamadas
nos reunimos con él platicamos todo el
tema que nos conllevaba en caracas con
él
y lo invitamos a uno de los encuentros
nacionales de matemáticas que
organizamos nosotros con cierta
regularidad digo con cierta regularidad
porque depende de la disponibilidad
quiere la gente de todo eso
organizamos ahorita estamos organizando
el onceavo encuentro nacional de
docentes de matemáticas y si la agenda
no me falla lo tenemos el miércoles 24 y
jueves 25 de octubre aquí en en la
ciudad de méxico es un encuentro de
docentes nacionales de docentes de
matemáticas tenemos otro también de
lengua de comunicación tenemos otro
también de informática y ahorita se
están organizando también los encuentros
de
de ciencia es decir si mal no recuerdo
tuvimos también la oportunidad de
conocer a salman khan en un evento de la
fundación carlos slim
y bueno platicamos con él tres minutos
acerca de todo este tema
algunas de las curiosidades que hemos
tenido en caracas de mí es que nosotros
tradicionalmente en el modelo quizá
ahora le hacemos toda una estructura
para la implementación de cualquier cosa
por más que sea recomendada no sea
obligatorio etcétera siempre hay un
respaldo de la secretaría académica de
la oficina nacional para que los
colegios estatales
los docentes implementen con toda
tranquilidad con toda seguridad de
respaldo la herramienta que recomendamos
en este caso
después del primer encuentro de docentes
de matemáticas ronda donde empezamos a
dar la capacitación bueno continuamos
con mucha comunicación oficial hacerlo
todos los directores de colegios
estatales también grabamos en el en el
canal de youtube del conalep grabamos
toda una capacitación acerca de cómo
usar khan academy tanto para docentes
como pagados como para alumnos
y cuando conocimos a rolando pues una de
las preguntas más intrigantes que traían
era
porque si invirtió tanto dinero que a la
cadena ser una plataforma intuitiva y de
autoaprendizaje en todas las palabras
tan bonitas
pues porque hacia nosotras tanta
capacitación y tanto evento y tanta cosa
de esa no y pues ya le comentábamos lo
que así es como trabajamos pues es decir
por más que la plataforma sea intuitiva
y autoaprendizaje y así
a la hora de quererla promover su uso en
en nuestros centros y los alumnos
teníamos que integrar el componente el
componente oficial lo que era bueno si
la recomiendo pero no la recomiendo
poniendo así o sticker no la recomiendo
dando herramientas a la capacitación y
entonces y por cosas también tuvimos la
oportunidad de ir a algunos estados a
capacitar porque estoy viendo tienen la
transmisión bueno en mi televisión no la
ven ustedes creo a los 100 que está
también compañera adriana con la quien
terminó tuve la oportunidad de cumplir
algunas invitaciones que les hicieron
para hacer capacitaciones en los estados
de las cuales ahorita también estamos
trabajando en esa parte de de poder
regresar a los estados
afortunadamente tenemos un país enorme
con 32 entidades federativas y bueno
aquí somos somos banda del pueblo somos
pocos pero hacemos muchos ruidos hacemos
todo lo que podemos hacernos todas las
capacitaciones que podemos ya sea
presenciales o virtuales talleres
webinars todo todo lo que lo que está a
nuestra mano entonces eso fue una cosa
curiosa con con rolando que si este
modelo que nosotros manejamos de llevar
toda la recomendación con un montón de
programas de capacitación webinars
oficios a eventos nacionales
reconocimientos a todos los docentes que
asisten a nuestros talleres de
capacitación a nuestros eventos
nacionales a todo lo que hacemos de
caracas y todos los docentes se les
entrega una constancia de la
capacitación a la cual aprendieron eso y
bueno vale no son muchos muchas personas
serían buenos un simple papel
pero tiene un valor increíble para para
los docentes en este caso queremos que
primero se haga partícipe de la
plataforma para que pueda posar con los
alumnos
y
hablábamos de qué cantidad de alumnos y
de vídeo
y de 2 y de docentes tenemos en nuestras
plataformas porque aparte de caracas
otras otras materias
por ejemplo nosotros hacemos alguna
encuesta nacional a los alumnos ya los
docentes y sabemos
sabemos que más de la mitad de los
alumnos estamos a los 169 lo lógico usan
canacar en el tema también que porque
nuestros alumnos son menores de edad en
la mayoría de los casos la única forma
de rastrear su actividad es por medio de
las cuentas de los docentes y tenemos
muchos alumnos que utilizan canacar y
sin una cuenta del docente no la usan
ellos entonces por eso luego cuando
estamos haciendo seguimiento de la
cantidad de alumnos que tenemos en
caracas este número varía hacia abajo
nunca va a variar hacia arriba varía
hacia abajo
pero sabemos que todo este esfuerzo que
hacemos si bien no lo vamos a poder
respirar alguna vez en algunas ocasiones
con otros entes
está este alumno se queda con ese
conocimiento y con esa experiencia y
sobre todo con la parte de
de que explore el autoaprendizaje que es
una cuestión que en lo personal yo veo
con más valor es decir
nosotros ya los los de factura modelos
70 en mis compañeros ochentas quizás
también todavía somos muy tradicionales
en el aprendizaje es decir es el
profesor es el libro en la materia el
contenido etcétera y en muy pocas áreas
de nuestra vida no necesariamente las
académicas son los de autoaprendizaje
sobre todo cuando igual queremos
aprender alguna travesura o algo que no
te recomiendan los mayores o sea ahí
donde aplicamos al aprendizaje el lo
interesante es aplicar el auto prensa/g
también las cuestiones académicas que es
lo que abra la nueva generación de
nuestros muchachos tienen ellos tienen
la
tienen que adaptarse a como la gente en
esta en esta época que les toca revivir
requiere esa habilidad de esa
competencia del autoaprendizaje y hasta
cierto punto como en jal academy y otras
plataformas no necesariamente hay
alguien que te está llevando que te está
marcando la pauta tiene sus algoritmos
donde dice qué porcentaje y si llega el
corrido de del recordatorio el
aprendizaje etc pero bueno no es no es
una persona nuestro papá
este no es tu profesor etcétera esa
parte en la que la que yo considero más
importante que que sobre todo los los
alumnos y nosotros también los mayores
aprovechando la oportunidad es la otra
forma es convocar academy para que
empecemos a entender como nuestro
cerebro si puede
si puede hacerse al hacerse de la
habilidad de la auto precisa g de que ya
los profesores y los especialistas
tomaron toda esta todo este talento que
tienen para explicar
y lo pusieron en los vídeos y lo
pusieron en ejercicios y como todas
estas personas programadoras
están analizando el comportamiento de
millones de usuarios de todas las edades
de todos los países de todas las
ubicaciones en todos los antecedentes y
están haciendo algoritmos para ver cuál
es la ruta de aprendizaje que más éxito
le ha causado a mi gente en el mundo no
entonces todo eso le hasta en la
plataforma lo que nosotros tenemos que
hacer como alumnos como docentes es
darle oportunidad a la plataforma que
nos empiece a transformar que nos
empieza a transformar en personas con
mayor capacidad de aprendizaje y cuando
lo logremos yo creo que la principal
responsabilidad que tenemos es
regresarlo es decir como profesores
tenemos nuestros alumnos es también
fácil pero también como profesores como
los alumnos tenemos una sociedad
que no tiene las mismas oportunidades
que nosotros no tiene una computadora
que no tiene un celular que le funcione
en internet
todas estas todas estas oportunidades
están ahí para que nosotros podamos
multiplicar
todo lo que estamos aprendiendo y sé lo
que se nos regresamos a otras otras
partes de nuestra propia familia y a
otras partes de la sociedad para que
pararse para que todos estos sus
beneficios sigan aumentando si no tiene
algo de rolando del hablando perdón de
salamanca ni de khan académica que es
una de las emisiones ustedes lo pueden
ver en su eslogan sirva lo recuerdo era
algo así como educación gratis para
todos los recuerdos y está en la página
principal pero es parte de de lo que
tenemos que tener en la mente para
para agradecer todo lo que nos está
dando que hago ya sube el volumen porque
creo que alguien quiere hablar y yo
tengo algunas trabajo no te preocupes
está perfecto muchas gracias de manuel
esta hemos estado al pendiente de las
preguntas acá en el chat
aparentemente no tenemos preguntas
dirigidas a ti son más como del uso de
la plataforma y eso lo vamos a ver en la
segunda mitad
e
aline christine creo que si no hay
muchas preguntas para el verdad no creo
que ninguna
ok
pero agradecemos muchísimo tu aportación
y manuel realmente esta
contextualización que nos has dado de
cómo se se ha estado trabajando con khan
academy desde hace tres años creo que es
bastante rica para los profesores que no
la no la sabían o no la han vivido
entonces muchísimas gracias por tu
tiempo por tu participación sabemos que
se te está empalmando con otro
compromiso entonces muchas muchas
gracias ahora toca el turno de adriana
flores que también les va a platicar un
poquito sobre lo que se está haciendo
con khan muchísimas gracias de manuel
gracias
adriana cómo estás buenos días
creo que está por ahí cerrado tu micro
todavía
por favor
cómo estás adrián a
perfecto adriana pues ya tuvimos el
contexto de manuel tú eres una de esas
maestras estrella que ha estado
trabajando con la herramienta desde hace
tres años
entonces quisiéramos que nos
compartieras un poquito quizá también
con base en lo que se hizo
en nuestra plática de la semana pasada
pero brevemente digamos tenemos unos 7
minutos 57 minutos para que nos cuentes
tu experiencia y cómo podemos nosotros
como profesores a lo mejor nuevos entre
comillas o que no hemos trabajado con la
herramienta sacarle provecho cuál ha
sido tu experiencia
d
adriana perdona que te interrumpa pero
nos están diciendo que no no te escuchas
que no te escucha incluso en la pantalla
trabajo en el hangout no nos aparece tu
foto o sea como que estás pero no estás
es un poco extraño yo si te escucho pero
en la transmisión no se escucha nada
podríamos hacer la prueba de que saliera
si volvieras a entrar rapidísimo
perdone una disculpa a todos los que nos
están escuchando pero
no sabemos qué pasó porque nosotros sí
podemos descubrir los que estamos como
de este lado
enmanuel christine collins y podemos
escuchar adriana pero la la transmisión
en youtube no
ok entonces personas que están en marcha
está funcionando
sí sí sí sí otra dicen que no se
escucharon como los últimos los dos
primeros dos minutos después de que yo
termine de hablar pero está un poco
extraño porque no se veía ni siquiera
adriana en la sesión digamos
ok pues vamos a ver
unos segundos para que regrese adrián a
para que comprobemos que esto se hace
vivo que la tecnología a veces nos pone
y trampillas
o que por ahí dice priscila rodríguez
que si se escucha lo mío pero marcela de
la cruz dice que no
[Música]
parece un poco confuso
ok
pues podemos empezar de nuevo con
adriana cuando regresa pero pero
mientras tanto igual y podríamos
resolver algunas de las dudas este que
abandona el programa de capacitación
quien está participando esta es una
oportunidad que tenemos para para
ustedes no es que estamos aquí para
resolver dudas y también ustedes van a
empezar a recibir reconocimientos para
su participación en este programa
entonces necesitamos
tu correo por ejemplo en el formulario
del registro para hacer eso y también
tienen que hacer algunas cosas para
lograr
el reconocimiento del módulo 1 y 2
entonces hay preguntas
sí bueno lo que están diciendo es que sí
que no se escuchó nada que tendría que
volver a empezar pero no sé dónde quedó
mi adriana querida yo creo que se nos
perdió en el ciberespacio
momentáneamente
bueno
lo que podemos hacer es aquí está
agregan esta sola área hacia es por
venir
como estas están cerrados un micro eh
está listo gracias a una disculpa
perfecto todos tuyos vas a ok ahora si
no me escuchó entonces él está otra vez
desde el principio que hay una disculpa
porque creo que si de hecho ahorita
emanuel se comunicó conmigo creo que él
también lo votó algo y como que
problemas técnicos pero este pues ya
aquí regresando
nosotros hemos implementado aquí dentro
del plantel el uso de la plataforma como
ya bien lo mencionaba este emanuel desde
hace tres años entonces yo creo que ese
es el primero el acuerdo como docentes
en generar este el conocimiento de la
plataforma en este empezar a utilizarla
y empezar a moverle oa preparador partes
así como que lo que yo les comentaba a
través de cuando nos daban juguete nuevo
y hay que aprender a usarlo entonces es
esta parte de que nosotros como docentes
debemos de preocuparnos por meternos al
manejo de la plataforma yo creo que no
es difícil a lo mejor a veces es el
desconocimiento o el nosa o el no estar
acostumbrados a utilizar este tipo de
de herramientas pero una vez que
nosotros aprendemos a manejarla es
extremadamente muy fácil porque como
docentes te ayudan a identificar
eficientes en tus alumnos por alumno no
es general sino que ésta tiene tenemos
la facilidad que la plataforma te dice
que alumno está fallando en qué cosas no
cuáles son los puntos malos que tiene
cada uno y a partir de eso pues poder
tomar líneas de acciones en el salón de
clases nosotros lo hemos tomado este
creo que se retiró no se escuchó como
una herramienta adicional o vamos a
decir como un recurso didáctico en
nuestras planeación es para aplicar todo
lo que viene en el programa ya sabemos
que ahorita nos están pidiendo mucho el
uso de las tic's y pues el manejo de la
plataforma o la utilización de esta
plataforma favorece mucho a esa parte en
la cual ya la educación viene diferente
el planteamiento viene diferente
y creo que es una excelente herramienta
además es muy para los chicos ha sido
muy muy amigable no se les gusta la
motivación de este sonido cuando tú
contestas bien y que te sale el confe
tito como que cuando no lo escuchan es
así como que chin lo tengo que intentar
y lo voy a hacer lo resolví bien y ya
está ellos solitos cuando escuchen el
sonidito es así como queda lo logré lo
hice bien no entonces también es
motivadora que es lo que yo he visto y
en la parte del concurso que estamos
ahorita en lo del campeonato
la clave es pasar comentábamos que tengo
un grupo que le ha echado muchas ganas
yo me he servido de haber detectado en
las en las gestiones cuáles serán los
deficientes que tenían estos chicos para
lo que yo estaba hablando que en
especial ese grupo es estamos en el
módulo de este análisis derivativo de
funciones que es este cálculo
diferencial y entonces empecé a detectar
que teníamos como unos problemas por con
el álgebra entonces agarré y dije ok
entonces las tareas que yo voy a asignar
van a ser específicamente de álgebra del
uso de éste
de como este puro procedimiento
algebraico no leyes de los signos este
leyes de los exponentes y todo este tipo
de cosas en las que yo detecte que tenía
deficiencias y que yo no puedo abarcar a
lo mejor ampliamente en clase porque
oscuro programa o cubro estas
deficiencias no entonces me apoyo del
uso de la plataforma para generar esto y
ya llevamos revisando hasta ellos mismos
ya dicen maestra si pude o la plataforma
éste tuve que hacer 20 ejercicios porque
me equivoco no m y me volvía a reír
reiniciar o cuando aparte de tipo de
ejercicios consecutivos entonces los
chicos dicen hasta que lo logré no
íbamos avanzando tenemos un grupo que
está próximo a llegar creo que la copa
número 16
en el que ellos y han utilizado la
plataforma específicamente para la
asignación de tareas que yo dejo que es
las deficiencias o los eficientes que
hemos detectado en el salón de clases y
también por ahí lo que veíamos de las es
cómo se llaman de las actividades de
crecimiento de mentales de crecimiento
es algo que también estamos trabajando
porque también el sistema con el web
todos los sistemas de medio superior
tenemos que trabajar con esta parte de
las habilidades obstrucciones entonces
yo soy tutora de un grupo y también me
apoye con el uso de estas actividades de
mentalidad de crecimiento para que lo
indicó este trabajarán la parte de
sensibilización de sensibilizarse en
cómo pueden aprender mejor cómo es que
funciona con las principales actividades
comprender a manejar los errores la
frustración y a partir de eso empezará a
generar cosas de éxito que es lo que
plantea estas actividades de crecimiento
que tuvo la oportunidad de revisar que
estamos trabajando también con ellos
entonces no nada más estamos atacando la
parte
de utilizarla como un recurso didáctico
para nivelar algunos alumnos y también
para apoyar en los programas sino
también para esta parte de las
habilidades socio emocionales y que
ellos tengan un poquito a lo mejor con
las con los casos que se plantean o los
vídeos que vienen de poder trabajar
también estas otras herramientas y que
también aquí en el plantel también
trabaja la parte de ciencias con el uso
de la plataforma asia también los
maestros de biología de física y de
química han utilizado la plataforma a
ellos y les costó un poquito más de
trabajo pero pues digo ya yo como
conocedora organizamos aquí en el
plantel un pequeño curso de capacitación
y me di a la tarea de explicarles las
herramientas de docente y de cómo poder
detectar a los chicos para los chicos es
un poquito más fácil yo lo he visto a
ellos no se les complica mucho el uso de
la plataforma porque
la ubican o la trasladan de un poquito
con la plataforma de facebook es así de
aparece mi nombre tengo mi imagen me
aparece un menú y todo no entonces yo
creo que a los que se más complica un
poquito a veces uso de la plataforma son
a los docentes nosotros este si hacemos
el cursillo entonces yo creo que a lo
mejor si se reúnen como academia o un
grupo hoy vamos a sentarnos y vamos a
explorar la plataforma
estaría bien y ya quién de esta
experiencia pues multiplicarla con los
demás docentes yo creo que esa es la
parte principal no primero la
disposición de los profesores después
generar este incentivo hacia los alumnos
de que hay un a los otros también
tenemos que tener planteles que la
plataforma tiene un peso en su
calificación entonces ya al tener una
una parte de evaluación éste ya se
vuelve como que más de compromiso de
hacerlo no sea igual y no es obligación
pero si se vuelve más aquí en la parte
que la utilice que éste cumpla con las
metas pues va a tener un incentivo que
en este caso es en parte su evaluación y
en cuanto a lo que es el concurso pues
yo personalmente con mis grupos internos
yo genero pequeños premios no sea
tampoco son que vamos a dar un premio a
todos que si hay un reconocimiento pero
si a esas personas que tuvieron la
oportunidad o el esfuerzo la dedicación
de estar en la plataforma
pues que se lleven un pequeño obsequio
digo yo lo hago con cosas sencillas unos
tipos una memoria o sea no tampoco cosas
extravagantes
que es mi manera de incentivarlos para
que ellos participen en estas
actividades
y se ha hecho y se ha hecho muy bien
digo somos uno de los planteles que ha
tenido uno de los mayores
reconocimientos en este manejo de la
plataforma de establecer la conectividad
dentro del colegio y por eso creo que
eso ha dado muy buenos resultados y
chicos incluso ya hábitos no necesitas
estar recibiendo que tienen que entrar
solitos en casa del cen transmite porque
lo ves en los reportes el tiempo que
están activos ellos y ves que si hay una
dedicación fuera de la escuela porque
aparte que la plata una de las
herramientas es que te marca el tiempo
activo de los chicos que lo hacen dentro
de la escuela y fuera del colegio
entonces esta parte es en donde nosotros
vemos que si hay un impacto bueno porque
los chicos lo están utilizando fuera de
la escuela en sus casas por medio de los
dispositivos móviles
y qué es lo que lo que nos ha ayudado a
cubrir esos deficientes y aquel chicos
que más que esto yo nunca lo había visto
no nunca me había topado con este tema
pero ahora ya lo sé ahora yo lo aprendí
y entonces es ahí donde generamos el
autoaprendizaje el que ellos empiezan a
ver cosas nuevas y que les llaman la
atención y que se están preocupando por
atenderlas o por aprender perfecto
muchísimas gracias a adriana ya tenemos
ahí dos perspectivas de profesores que
han estado utilizando la aplicación
desde hace tres años como manuel y como
tú que son contextos quizás distintos y
enfoques muy distintos pero los dos son
muy ricos
y te agradecemos muchísimo tu tiempo tu
participación estamos al pendiente del
chat y creo que hasta el momento no hay
preguntas dirigidas a ti específicamente
las que hemos visto son más como del uso
de la herramienta pero de todas formas
bueno si salen por ahí alguna pregunta
pues ya te lo estaremos esté pasando
ahorita antes de que termine la sesión
vale
sí claro muchas gracias a adriana y
tenemos 20 minutos aproximadamente
para cerrar la sesión entonces lo que
vamos a hacer es hacer como un repaso de
lo que ha estado pasando desde agosto
que se empezó con el programa de
capacitación y los tres módulos en el
módulo 1 se tenía que ver o se vio los
primeros pasos en khan academy el plan
de acción para 18 de 2018 2019 la
implementación de las mejoras para
mejores prácticas lineamientos conocer
la plataforma las nuevas funcionalidades
de la plataforma y acá súper importante
que hay y se incorporó contenido de
mentalidad de crecimiento entonces eso
fue en el mes de agosto como para
contextualizar y hay profesores y ya lo
hemos estado viendo en los chats a lo
largo de todos estos webinars que ya
tienen mucho tiempo utilizando la
herramienta y hay otros que apenas están
incorporando entonces está digamos como
lineamientos que se empezaron desde
agosto pues fueron súper útiles para
todos los que
dieron sus primeros pasos en la
plataforma apenas entre agosto y
septiembre se trabajó que es el
campeonato porque el campeonato comenzó
el 10 de septiembre y son 10 semanas que
era el campeonato como podemos comenzar
cómo motivar a los alumnos durante el
reto cómo reconocer sus logros qué debo
hacer para ser reconocido como un
maestro campeón cómo entrenar a otros
asignar tareas
las nuevas características de la
plataforma para fomentar una mentalidad
de crecimiento y el resumen del vídeo
del módulo 1 para los que no pudieron
participar en esta sesión estamos ya
comenzando con el módulo 3 que abarcará
todo el mes de octubre noviembre y
diciembre entonces se va a trabajar como
motivar a los alumnos con hacer
ceremonias para reconocer los logros y
esfuerzos de los alumnos en la escuela
la preparación para el examen y el
reconocimiento para ustedes como estos
por su esfuerzo por su tiempo por su
capacitación vale entonces bueno en el
módulo 1 tuvimos que haber participado
en el webinar del mes de agosto
y haber ya hecho el registro en khan
academy crear una clase asignar
contenido y completar la tarea asignada
no se preocupen por los que no lo hayan
hecho todavía están a tiempo de hacerlo
porque si no participaron en el webinar
de agosto o no han hecho todo esto se
puede hacer todavía y vamos ahorita
después de esta breve explicación les
voy a dar una una demo en vivo para que
vean ustedes qué es lo que se tiene que
hacer sale y hay reconocimiento para sus
esfuerzos son reconocimientos no tanto
certificados son reconocimientos para
ustedes por las horas de capacitación
por unirse a la comunidad de educadores
de docentes perdón innovadores y bueno
por recibir el apoyo de especialistas
del equipo de clara academia en mexico
ojo aquí super importante el registro
tuvieron que ustedes que haber llenado
un formulario con el correo que
utilizaron para khan academy para
recibir este reconocimiento por su
esfuerzo en pantalla está la liga pero
yo creo que también podemos pasarse las
vía correo electrónico oa lo mejor en el
en el chat no sé christine si se las
podemos pegar si ya compartir lo que ya
mencionar algo hay personas que están
diciendo estoy recibiendo correos
pidiendo mi registro hay muchos docentes
que han registrado al programa de
capacitación pero con su correo personal
o un correo que no tiene nada que ver
con su cuenta de canacar a mí lo más
importante para registrarse es que
tienes una cuenta de khan academy por
eso vas a recibir correos así también
tienen que participar en el campeonato y
todavía hay poco
es más a cinco semanas de reto y para
recibir el reconocimiento del módulo 2
esto es algo que tienen que hacer
entonces no sé si hay preguntas o dudas
pero hay algunas personas con preguntas
ok entonces esa es la liga para el
registro hay también un documento con
información del programa para que sepan
de qué es de qué se trata cuánto tiempo
abarca en fin hay también una liga de
soporte técnico esta es bien importante
porque luego nos dicen en el chat en
estos webinars es que mis alumnos no
pudieron hacer esto no pueden ver tal o
cual actividad
ok siempre hay una liga de soporte
tratemos principalmente de checar lo que
viene en la ayuda por favor pero bueno
también si tienen ustedes dudas o
preguntas hay un correo electrónico que
pueden escribirnos que es o la arroba
khan academy punto o hereje
sale aquí está lo del registro del
programa y bueno vamos a hacer una demo
breve lo primero y más importante es que
podamos registrarnos para registrarnos
tienen que entrar a la liga en ese punto
khan academy punto o hereje
y a través de esta liga creo que no
estoy compartiendo esa pantalla
permítanme un segundito
a ver de nuevo
ahí está creo que ya se ve en cuenta ok
entonces cuando nosotros entramos a ese
punto khan academy punto o hereje damos
click al botón de regístrate y nos da
tres opciones registrarnos con nuestra
cuenta de google con una cuenta de
facebook o con el correo electrónico
la sugerencia siempre por favor es que
nos registremos con la cuenta de correo
electrónico porque después podemos dejar
de utilizar la cuenta de facebook
o perdemos el password o lo que sea
entonces por favor con la cuenta de
correo electrónico que ustedes utilicen
regularmente que en este caso deberán
ser arroba por ejemplo en el caso de los
profesores del conalep pues arroba
conalep un total de un punto de mx
registren se con esa cuenta por favor
para que puedan entrar a la plataforma
una vez que nosotros entramos a la
plataforma es muy fácil empezar a
trabajar nos vamos al apartado dice
bueno siempre nos da una bienvenida que
dice que ya empezó el campeonato voy a
profundizar en esto un poquito más en
unos segunditos pero lo que tengo que
hacer es crear clases entonces es muy
fácil darle clic en agregar una clase y
tengo que poner el nombre de mi clase
por ejemplo
mate 3 o mate 3,13 y yo lo puedo
configurar como yo quiera con el nombre
de mi grupo de la materia saleh o
incluso puedo importar clases desde
google clason por ahí había una pregunta
de cómo hacerlo
esto es directamente desde que tú creas
la clase desde cero entonces importa tu
clase desde google caster conecta con
una cuenta de clase en este caso la
cuenta en donde yo estoy trabajando yo
no tengo una cuenta de google classroom
activa pero bastaría con que yo diera
clic en mi cuenta de correo electrónico
si yo ya tengo mis clases de clase y
creadas puedo escoger qué clase es la
que yo quiero jalar y automáticamente se
me van a vaciar digamos los usuarios acá
en khan academy ese va a ser el enlace
entre las dos plataformas
puedo simplemente ingresar el nombre de
mi clase
darle clic en siguiente que sería lo
mismo que quería yo si le diera clic en
la opción de clase
para que me jale toda la información
y me va a pedir que seleccione el
contenido que yo quiero trabajar con esa
clase está un poco lento esto
déjenme intentarlo nuevamente
mate 3 am vamos a ver
trópico
más
[Música]
no vamos a más
no sé si será mi internet creo que sí ok
entonces aquí ya tengo que añadir mis
cursos o sea el contenido de mis clases
por ejemplo yo quisiera agregar
contenido de matemáticas salen
elementales pero lo mejor también algo
de geometría básica
contenido de 3º de secundaria por
ejemplo de matemáticas y algo bien
importante específicamente para el
campeonato las actividades de mentalidad
de crecimiento nos dan más puntos
entonces les sugerimos siempre agregar
las las actividades de mentalidad de
crecimiento entonces le damos clic en
siguiente todas las clases generan un
código sale
entonces este código ya sea que lo sé lo
podamos dar a los chicos para que ellos
entren directamente desde la página que
les acabo de pasar ese punto khan
academy punto o hereje o podemos agregar
a los estudiantes con estos métodos por
ejemplo importarlos desde google claro
que es lo que les enseñaba hace un
momento enviar una invitación por correo
electrónico o crear una cuenta de khan
academy para nuestros alumnos
yo considero que en muchas de las
ocasiones lo más fácil es pasarles el
código e incluso tenemos opción de
imprimir las instrucciones para que
ellos puedan acceder vale listo clase
creada estos son nuestros siguientes
pasos y podemos encontrar los ejercicios
asignarlo a los estudiantes y también
ver la página de la clase para dar
seguimiento al avance de los chicos vale
ahora bien muchos de ustedes ya tienen
las clases creadas y por ahí preguntaban
bueno cómo puedo hacer el vínculo con
google classroom cuando nosotros tenemos
las clases creadas basta con que nos
vayamos a nuestra clase a la que ustedes
quieran por ejemplo no se está de física
y me voy a la configuración
en la configuración viene la opción para
sincronizar con google clase entonces
basta con que yo pueda habilitar esa
opción
y seleccionar bueno con qué clase lo
quieres lo quieres vincular lo quieres
sincronizar es exactamente lo mismo que
si estuviéramos creando la clase desde
cero me va a aparecer el menú de todas
las clases que yo tengo
creadas en google chrome para poder
seleccionar la ahora para efecto del
campeonato es importante que tomemos en
cuenta dos cosas una nuestras clases
tienen que tener por lo menos 10 alumnos
saleh
y número 2 eliminen por favor también
las clases que estén inactivas es decir
las clases que tuvieron en semestres o
años pasados eliminen las por favor
también aquí desde la configuración
pueden eliminar esas clases para que no
nos estorben y entonces podamos
participar en el campeonato únicamente
con las clases que nosotros tenemos
activas sale como puedo asignar
contenido ya creé mi clase ya tengo mis
10 estudiantes ahora como les les pongo
el contenido les asignó las actividades
ok
por ejemplo en esta de asesoría de
matters
yo entro a mi clase y entonces aquí
tengo el contenido por ejemplo tengo de
mentalidad de crecimiento pero también
tengo de matemáticas elementales
entonces voy a seleccionar yo quiero
ponerles una actividad de matemáticas
tenemos que para participar en el
campeonato tenemos que asignar por lo
menos tres actividades a la semana
entonces creo que está bastante fácil de
lograr por ejemplo de esta unidad de
introducción a las sumas y las restas
por ejemplo yo le puedo desplegar y ya
sea que yo quiera asignar toda la unidad
y automáticamente se le van a asignar
aquí 25 actividades o puedo decir bueno
quiero asignarles esta que tiene cuatro
ejercicios relacionados y entonces le
doy clic aquí en
a signar se la voy a asignar a cada
estudiante ok de mi clase de asesoría de
matemáticas 1 cuando es la fecha límite
está yo la puedo modificar hoy es 9
entonces quisiera darle a lo mejor
tiempo hasta el 12 de octubre también
pudiera modificar por la hora en el caso
de esta clase mía bueno aquí no tengo
estudiantes pero si lo estuviese me van
a aparecer me va a aparecer la lista
sale también puedo guardar y asignar más
tarde esto es importante a lo mejor
estoy pensando en dejarles esta
actividad pero no en este preciso
momento o simplemente le doy clic en
asignar actividad y ya se va sale así es
como empiezo a asignarle el contenido y
puedo jugar con ese contenido aquí en
esta
en este menú de mentalidad de
crecimiento de matemáticas de 1º
secundaria dependiendo del contenido que
yo haya seleccionado que quiero
incorporar en mi clase ahora ya que
estamos participando en el campeonato y
que nos quedan todavía cinco semanas
vamos a la mitad no es tarde para poder
participar es importante que revisemos
el avance que estamos teniendo como les
decía tienen que asignar tres
actividades a la semana pero todos los
chicos tienen que finalizar esas tres
actividades entonces se van
desbloqueando niveles digamos vamos
obteniendo copas entonces cuando yo le
doy clic en el inicio en donde dice
revisa tu avance aquí me dice por el
campeonato completa tres tareas en
promedio y vamos subiendo de nivel o
vamos desbloqueando los niveles y las
copas entonces aquí por ejemplo nos
marca que tenemos todavía 37 días
restantes para completar el nivel 6
conforme nosotros vayamos
avanzando a estos niveles se nos van a
ir coloreando y se nos van a ir
desbloqueando copas recuerden que es un
concurso sí pero entre ustedes mismos
con su propio grupo no están compitiendo
ustedes con otros planteles digamos es
una forma de reforzar el contenido y el
progreso de sus alumnos dentro del
propio del propio salón sale entonces
aquí por ejemplo podríamos darle clic en
revisa tu progreso pues no tenemos
progreso nuevo en este caso pues son
clases demo de nosotros pero ustedes
fácilmente podrían revisar este avance
en su plataforma
ahora para quienes no han podido revisar
el contenido por ejemplo de lo que se
dio en agosto desde agosto pueden
acceder a la página de youtube y buscar
el canal de khan academy español y
entonces aquí tenemos todos los vídeos
de todo lo que nosotros hemos estado
subiendo en los webinars por ejemplo y
en los módulos para que puedan revisar
la información
desde él desde el primer webinar por
ejemplo aquí está el del módulo 2 lo que
se ha estado haciendo del módulo 3 que
estamos ahorita el parqué por ejemplo el
promocional de que el campeonato llega a
mexico en fin aquí están todos los
vídeos para que ustedes puedan
revisarlos por favor y pueden ponerse al
corriente en todo lo que he estado
haciendo no sé si hasta el momento hay
alguna duda
el link christine un estado muy al
pendiente yo del chat
no hay preguntas pero hay algunas
personas que están compartiendo su
experiencia en la programa de
capacitación y también en el campeonato
y esto es algo muy importante para
nosotros entonces estoy compartiendo
nuestro correo o la canacar mi punto o
hereje ok
ok y también es importante cuando
ustedes celebren el progreso a sus
alumnos recuerden que a nosotros nos
interesa mucho que nos compartan su
experiencia entonces tenemos un hashtag
que es campeonato 2018 si ustedes toman
vídeos de sus alumnos fotografías de sus
alumnos celebrando su progreso o su
avance su y la sube en las redes
sociales o las comparten entonces
utilicen el hashtag de campeonato 2018 o
en su defecto si nos hicieran el enorme
favor de compartirnos todo este
contenido al correo que nos acaba de
mencionar christine o la arroba khan
academy punto o hereje nos ayuda
muchísimo porque incluso estamos
preparando algo muy padre para ustedes
para el mes de noviembre
entonces nos encantaría tener ese
material que ustedes viven todos los
días
no sé si haya por ahí alguna duda algún
otro comentario de algo creo que estamos
terminando justo en tiempo
al principio de la sesión comentaban lo
declararon y eso ya lo tocaste entonces
creo que ya como dice christine son más
este experiencias que tienen los
profesión ok excelente pues sí ya no
tenemos ninguna otra duda agradecemos
muchísimo su tiempo
hay otro webinar me parece creo que la
próxima semana el 16 si no me equivoco
entonces pues nos estamos viendo en la
próxima semana muchísimas gracias por su
tiempo gracias a adriana gracias a
manuel y si tienes escribanos por favor
gracias a todos gracias a manuel y
también a adriana y a ustedes también
muchas gracias
ay